Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Tekne Mezioğlu.
Ich bin auf der Station Ars Stetik.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen heute das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Gerne, bitte schön.
Ja, zunächst benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Dann können wir weiterführen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Michael Hoffmann.
Michael Hoffmann, könnten Sie bitte
Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Nachname ist Havi Heinrich, Ovi Otto,
Doppel F wie Friedrich, M wie Marta, A wie Anton, Doppel N wie Nordpol.
Mein Name ist Michael, M wie Marta, I wie Ida, C wie Cesar, Havi Heinrich,
A wie Anton, I wie Emil und L wie Ludwig.
L wie Ludwig, vielen Dank.
Herr Hoffmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
58 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren, Herr Hoffmann?
Am 14. September 1967.
67, OK.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Hoffmann?
1,80 Meter groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ca. 82 Kilogramm.
82 Kilogramm.
OK, vielen Dank für die Information.
Was für ein Saison, Herr Hoffmann?
Also ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit Tagen
tatsächlich vermehrt Luftnot habe, wenn ich mich anstrengen.
Luftnot, wie viele Tage?
Seit ca. drei Wochen.
Es ist ca. drei Wochen.
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Ursache?
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie sich Luftnot fühlen?
Nein, wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich mich anstrengen, dann habe ich sehr oft
diese Luftnot.
Ja, seit drei Wochen.
Ja, haben Sie noch früher, hatten Sie schon früher ähnliche Wäschewerden oder?
Nein, sowas hatte ich noch nie.
Nur seit drei Wochen.
Gibt es eine Veränderung in den letzten drei Wochen?
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Was meinen Sie?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Nein.
Okay. Haben Sie noch Schmerzen?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen, nein.
Keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche andere Wäschewerden?
Gleichzeitig?
Ich bin müde.
Ich bin sehr schnell
ermütbar geworden.
Wie bitte?
Ich werde sehr schnell müde.
Ja, müde.
Fühlen Sie sich sehr müde.
Mit der Zeit diese Beschwerden schlimmer geworden oder?
Ja.
Die Luftnot tritt auf nur bei Bewegung, wenn ich richtig feststehe.
Ja, wenn ich mich anstrengen.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, wenn ich
liege, dann habe ich manchmal auch Luftnot.
Ja, haben Sie auch Luftnot.
Okay.
Wenn Sie flach liegen.
Richtig.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie?
Zwei.
Bei letzter Woche zwei Stück.
Ja, letzte Woche.
Aber das ist ganz neu. Früher?
Vorher kann ich das ganz.
Ganz normal. Okay.
Gibt es gleichzeitig Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Enger Gefühl?
Ich habe ein wenig Herzrasen vermehrt.
Ja.
Herzrasen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck.
Ich habe Diabetes.
Ich habe eine Cholesterinerhöhung.
Und ich habe auch Vorhofflimmern.
Haben Sie noch eine Vorhofflimmern?
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Wann war letzte Kontrolle beim Kardiologen?
Letztes Jahr.
Ich gehe einmal im Jahr zum Kardiologen.
Ja, aber letztes Jahr.
Letztes Jahr.
Okay.
Haben Sie mit Ihrem Bluthochdruck gemessen oder?
Der ist normal.
Wann war letzte Kontrolle?
Ich messe den jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag.
Zum Beispiel gestern.
Wie hoch war?
Der war 140 zu 85.
140 und 85.
Genau.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikament?
Ja, ich nehme Rhabibri, für meinen Blutdruck.
Für das Belehrer.
Wie bitte?
Rhabibri.
Ja, wie viel?
5 mg einmal morgens.
5 mg einmal morgen.
Nehmen Sie Rhabibri regelmäßig.
Natürlich.
Okay. Und gibt es noch andere?
Ich nehme noch für meinen Vorhofflimmern Apixaban ein.
Ein Blutverdünner.
Apixaban, ja.
Morgens und abends.
Morgen und abends.
Dann nehme ich noch Bisopolol ein.
5 mg morgens einmal.
Ja, Bisopolol.
Dann Metformin für meinen Zucker.
1000 mg morgens und abends.
Und einmal Atorvastatin für meinen Cholesterin.
20 mg einmal abends.
Atorvastatin.
Wie viel?
20.
20 mg abends.
Richtig.
Einmal abends.
Okay.
Herr Hoffmann.
Habt ihr noch Brustschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe keine Brustschmerzen.
Keine Brustschmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Fieber?
Nein.
Ist derzeit keine Fieber.
Kopfschmerzen, Schlafstörungen,
Konzentrationsstörungen.
Ja, Schlafstörungen, weil ich wegen Luftnot ab und zu aufwache.
Ansonsten habe ich keine Kopfschmerzen.
Nein.
Okay.
Wie ist die Apotheke?
Etwas weniger als sonst.
Ja, etwas weniger als die Apotheke.
Und wie ist Ihr Durst?
Normal.
Ganz normal.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß, Kalzschweiß?
Nein.
Keine.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Hoffmann, wo wohnen Sie?
Zu Hause.
Welche Etage?
Zwei Etagen.
Zwei Etage.
Wenn Sie hoch gehen,
Entschuldigung, Sie bitte.
Können Sie ganz gut hoch gehen oder?
Nein.
Wenn ich zwei Etagen laufe, hochsteige,
dann habe ich wirklich auch Luftnot
und auch Herzrasen.
Okay.
Deswegen
haben Sie schon Ihren Hausarzt besucht?
Nein.
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay.
Anspracheerkrankungen haben Sie,
Bluthochdruck und Zuckerkrankheit,
Cholesterinimie und haben Sie schon...
Sie haben schon gesagt, Vorfliemen.
Vorfliemen und Diabetes, ne?
Und Diabetes, ja.
Habe ich das nicht gesagt.
Würden Sie schon mal operieren, Herr Hoffmann?
Nein.
Nein, nicht.
Haben Sie noch Allergien gegen etwas?
Nein.
Medikament oder sowas?
Okay.
Und Herr Hoffmann, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Früher hatten Sie schon geraucht oder?
Niemals.
Super, super gut zu hören, Herr Hoffmann.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz, ganz selten.
Einmal im Jahr oder zweimal.
Einmal im Jahr.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht diese Frage persönlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert oder?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Niemals, super.
Und Herr Hoffmann, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja.
Die sind beide sehr alt.
Gibt es hier gar keine Erkrankung?
Beide haben Zucker, beide haben Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Ansonsten haben sie nichts Wildes.
Okay.
Wie alt ist Ihr Vater?
Die sind beide über 90 schon.
Über 90, super.
Okay.
Beide.
Beide Hypertonin und Zuckerkrankheit.
Genau.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Bürokaufmann.
Bürokaufmann?
Richtig.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe das notiert und
wir haben...
Herr Hoffmann, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ja.
Ich würde gerne, dass man mal guckt, ob mein Herz gut funktioniert.
Ich habe Angst, dass mein Herz nicht gut funktioniert.
Ja, wir werden alle Möglichkeiten untersuchen, Herr Hoffmann.
Sie haben schon seit
circa einem Jahr...
Bitte?
Sie haben schon
circa einem Jahr nicht kontrolliert.
Ja, richtig.
Deswegen sollen wir Ihre alle Befunde,
alle Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf...
Ja, deswegen
eine Gerinnung im Lungen.
Und auch...
Was bedeutet das?
Ja, wegen
ihrer Vorfühlung entstehen viele Gerinnungen.
Und dann...
Aber die stimmen doch an Blutverdünner.
Ja, aber haben wir keine Kontrollbefunde.
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ja, einmal ist es eine Kontrolle
beim Kardiologen.
Das braucht man nicht bei diesem Medikament.
Ja, aber haben Sie Akte dabei oder?
Ich habe Apiksaban.
Apiksaban, okay.
Nur Apiksaban.
Ja.
Ich werde zunächst Ihre Körper untersuchen,
dann etwas Blut abnehmen,
dann ein EKG schreiben und im Labor
Blutbild und Nierenwerte, Leberwerte und Herzensüme
kontrollieren lassen und dann würde ich gerne eine kardiologische Konsül
veranlassen.
Kann das auch was von der Lunge sein?
Habe ich so Luftnothabe?
Ja, können wir für Sie in der Notaufnahme
eine Behandlung geben.
Wie bitte?
In der Notaufnahme werde ich für Sie
eine Behandlung verabreichen.
Sauerstoff und
noch etwas.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich warte jetzt auf Sie, oder?
Oder möchten Sie noch was sagen?
Darf ich?
Herr Hoffmann, ist Ihnen das geschwollene Bein aufgefallen?
Ja, etwas in dem Bein, leichte Riemen.
Bis Knie oder bis Knirchen?
Nicht ganz bis zum Knie, Fußknöcheln.
Danke.
Herr Hoffmann, haben Sie Heißstau bemerkt?
Ich habe das selber nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ich habe nicht drauf geachtet.
Okay.
Sehen Sie blass aus?
Nein.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Grippe oder Erkältung gehabt?
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen, besonders am Not?
Nein.
Sagen Sie mir bitte in letzter Zeit, oder?
Hatten Sie einen Herzinfarkt?
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Super.
Ich habe nur das Vorflimmer.
Wie viele Mal gehen Sie zum Wasserlassen am Nachts?
Einmal in der Nacht.
Einmal, danke.
Ist Ihnen übel? Haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwitendelig?
Ja, wenn ich Lufttunnel habe, wenn ich zwei Tage laufen, dann habe ich auch Schwinde.
Außerdem habe ich keine asthmabranche alle.
Was haben Sie?
Asthmabranche alle.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine allergische
irreversible oder allergische
Atemerkrankung.
Ich habe keine Arachnägel.
Ja, ich weiß. Danke schön.
Okay, dann starten wir.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag, Herr Obans.
Ich habe einen
neuen Patienten aufgenommen, wenn Sie Zeit haben.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Bitte.
Michael Hoffmann,
58 Jahre alt,
geboren, 14.9.1967,
1,80 Meter groß und 82 Kilo.
Es geht um Michael Hoffmann.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns
ca.
drei Wochen bestehende Progrediente Luftnot und Müde vor.
Müdigkeit.
Müdigkeit, ja Müdigkeit.
Und
nach laut Angaben der Patienten
sind die Beschwerden vor drei Wochen besonders Luftnot plötzlich aufgetreten.
Sie berichtet
über
gleichzeitig aufgetretenen Herzrasen auch.
Entschuldigung, bitte.
Und
begleitend
Luftnotbedingte Schlafstörungen und
ja,
letzte war
Blut,
Tensionkontrolle war normal.
Blutdruck.
Ja, Bluthoch, Tension.
Ja,
Blutdruck.
Blutdruck war normal.
Und bei der Veketative amnese
ist unaufwendig bis auf eine Luftnotbedingte Schlafstörung.
Bei der Erkrankung an amnese erwähnte sie
Hypatonie, Cholesterinemie,
Pflemen und Diabetes mellitus.
Und
vor Operation amnese ist unaufwendig.
Allergien amnese wurde verleint.
Bei der Medikament amnese ergaben sie
eine Ramipril 5 mg einmal morgen,
Apixaban morgen und abend,
Bisoprolol einmal morgen, Medformin
1000 mg morgen und abends und so wie Atorvastastin
20 mg abend einmal.
Noxon amnese wurde verleint.
Nicht auffällig.
Sehr seltener Alkoholkonsum wurde beherrt.
Drogenkonsum wurde verleint.
Die Familien amnese ergab
Mutter und Vater, beide sind über 90,
Arterie Hypatonie und Diabetes mellitus bei ihnen bekannt.
Sie sind geschieden,
keine Kinder, sie ist Bürokaufer.
Wer ist geschieden? Er.
Er ist geschieden,
hat keine Kinder und er ist Bürokaufer.
Auch unter amnese habe ich einen Verdacht auf
pulmonäre Embolle.
Einen was?
Pulmonäre Embolle.
Aus meiner Sicht
sind neue aufgetretene seit zwei Wochen plötzlich aufgetretene Luftnot,
Müdigkeit und Herzblut.
Plötzlich aufgetreten oder progradiert?
Wie bitte?
Plötzlich aufgetreten oder progradierter Luftnot?
Ja progradierter, bestehende und progradierter Luftnot.
Sprechen dafür.
Die Fragzeitenkommens
Herzinsuffizienz und Akutkornalzentrum in Betracht.
Warum sagen oder warum denken Sie an die
Lungenembolie statt an eine Herzinsuffizienz?
Hat der Patient Unterschenkelödeme?
Leider habe ich nicht gefragt.
Das ist wichtig, müssen Sie fragen, wer Unterschenkelödeme hat.
Unterschenkelödemen ist sehr wichtig.
Der Patient nimmt ja Blutverdünner ein.
Ja, die Patientin nimmt regelmäßig Apixaban.
Ist dann eine Lungenembolie wahrscheinlich oder unwahrscheinlich?
Ja normalerweise
kann sein.
Selten, sehr selten.
Aber was ist wahrscheinlich?
Was ist wahrscheinlich?
Was meinen Sie?
Sie haben ja eine Herzinsuffizienz gesagt.
Was spricht hier für eine Herzinsuffizienz?
Und was spricht hier für eine Lungenembolie?
Ich habe
das Lungenot gedacht wegen
Vor- und Unterkontrolle.
Seit einem Jahr hatte er keine Kontrolle.
Und deswegen würde ich gerne
Routine-Untersuchungen kontrollieren.
Was kontrollieren?
Zum Beispiel EKG und INR und Herzensimen.
INR brauchen Sie nicht kontrollieren.
Ja, bei Apixaban braucht man das nicht.
Ja, warum nicht?
Aber was Sie kontrollieren können,
ist die Herzfrequenz.
Vielleicht, er hat ja einen Voropplenmann.
Ja.
Vielleicht hat er eine Pachyarythmie.
Ja, kann sein.
Das kann vielleicht eine Herzinsuffizienz begünstigen.
Ja, natürlich.
Oder?
Mit Belastungsdysknoe, mit Östlatschenkelproblemen,
mit nächtlichem, nächtlicher Luftnot, sodass er
mit erhöhtem Kissen schlafen muss.
Ja, zwei Kissen, wenn es so ist.
Spricht das eher für eine Lungenembolie oder für eine Herzinsuffizienz?
Ja, das entspricht eine Herzinsuffizienz.
Sehr gut.
Genau.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall eine Herzinsuffizienz hier prärapieren.
Tatsächlich.
Weil die Symptome sprechen eher dafür,
statt für eine Lungenembolie.
Ja.
Ich dachte, eine Lungenembolie ist eine
Notfallbesch.
Und nicht seit drei Wochen.
Ja.
Sie haben ja nicht drei Wochen.
Er hat die Beschwerden seit drei Wochen.
Zum Beispiel seit gestern Abend.
Wie therapiert man oder was macht man wenn
diagnostisch für eine Untersuchung bei Herzinsuffizienz?
Ja, ich würde gerne
einen EKG schreiben.
Laborntersuchung und eine Eko-Kardiographie.
Ja.
Was machen Sie noch?
Was bestimmen Sie im Blut für einen besonderen
Parameter?
Bei Herzinsuffizienz?
Im Blut?
Ja.
Laborkontroll. Was kontrollieren Sie?
Leber und Bier.
Bei Herzinsuffizienz?
Ja, könnte zum Beispiel kreitend hoch sein.
Ja, aber ein Parameter.
Ein besonderer Parameter bei Herzinsuffizienz.
Wie heißt dieser Parameter?
Bei der Herzinsuffizienz
Kortenensimen.
OBNP.
Schonmal gehört.
BNP.
OBNP.
Können Sie mir bitte erklären?
Das ist das Brain Natuoretic Peptide.
Das wird in dem ...
Kennen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Sie lachen.
Ja, deswegen ...
... ein Nikturin.
Okay.
Ja, Brain Natuoretic Peptide.
Genau.
Ja, ein Nikturin.
Brain Natuoretic Peptide.
Das müssen Sie nochmal nachlesen, aber kennen Sie wahrscheinlich auch.
Nein?
Wenn Sie den Verdacht auf eine Herzinsuffizienz haben,
sollten Sie diesen Parameter bestimmen.
Ja, okay.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Sie haben gesagt, ich mache Laborkontrolle,
ich mache ein EKG, ein Herzultraschall.
Was machen Sie noch?
Ja, anschließlich würde ich gerne einen Kardiolukschild, Konzil, anfordern.
Ja, was machen Sie noch in der Notaufnahme?
Bei der Notaufnahme?
Ja, Vitalparameter überwachen.
Ja, das sowieso.
Das machen Sie sowieso.
Was noch?
Eine Röntgen.
Eine Röntgen-Torak.
Richtig.
Warum machen wir das? Warum?
Man kann eine
Kardiomegalie überprüfen.
Was noch?
Ja, und Lungengewebe beurteilen.
Ja, nicht so gut.
Was kann man aber sehen in der Lunge eventuell?
Bei der Herzinsuffizienz sehr spezifisch, oder?
Ja, genau. Was sieht man dann meistens in der Lunge?
Kardiomegalie und auch
Dach oder?
Man sieht das? Wasser in der Lunge vielleicht.
Wasser.
Pleuralgus.
Pleuralgus, ja.
Ja, genau.
Das ist wichtig.
Okay, der Patient hat Luftnot.
Der Patient hat ein Unterschenkelödema oder
Kröschenödema. Der Patient hat eine Tachiarithmie.
Wie läuft die Therapie ab, diese
Patientin mit Herzinsuffizienz?
Was für eine Therapie leiten Sie ein?
Die Therapie
am Anfang bei der Notfall
Antiodemtherapie.
Bitte was? Antiodem?
Wie nennt man das im Medizinisch?
Nicht Antiodemtherapie, sondern?
Wir...
Diuretische Therapie.
Ja, Diuretische.
Mit welchen Medikamenten machen wir das?
Wie soll ich sagen? Ich weiß es nicht, aber
Inutropik und?
Mit Diuretika.
Pure damit.
Sowas in der Art.
Ja, als Diuretika meinen Sie?
Genau.
Es ist die diuretische Therapie.
Und was war er noch zur Frequenzkontrolle?
Er hat ja eine Tachiarithmie wahrscheinlich.
Er hat eine sogenannte dekompensierte
Herzinsuffizienz.
Was müssen Sie noch geben an Medikamenten?
Bei der dekompensierte Herzinsuffizienz.
Können Sie bitte...
Diuretika und hochdosiert Beta Blocker.
Beta Blocker.
Er hat ja schon einen Beta Blocker Bisoprolol drin.
Aber das ist noch nicht die Maximal Dosierung.
Wir müssen das erhöhen.
Und wenn das nicht ausreicht, kann man noch zusätzlich zum Beispiel
Digitales geben, Digitoxin zum Beispiel.
Das kann man geben.
Das kennen Sie, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
So lange haben wir gar nicht.
Okay.
Normalerweise.
Und dann können Sie, wenn Sie den Patienten
etwas therapiert haben, der mit der Herzfrequenz ein bisschen runtergekommen ist,
dann können Sie natürlich auch ein kardiologisches Konzil anfordern,
wenn Sie den Patienten mit dem Verdacht auf Herzinsuffizienz
aufgenommen haben.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Verstanden?
Ja, alles verstanden.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Herr Ekbemöz, haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Geile Fragen.
Hat jemand anderes Fragen?
Oder gibt es Fragen?
Alles verstanden?
Alle nicht gemacht?
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte.
Die Beta Blocker reduziert das Pirellot oder Afterlot?
Beta Blocker morgens oder morgens und abends geben.
Er hat Visoprolol drin, 10 Milligramm aufzudosieren.
Er hat schon 5 drin.
Noch mal auf maximal Dosierung machen.
Danke.
Nichts mit Pirellot, Afterlot.
Ist die Therapie ganz alle nur Diuretika und Beta Blocker?
Ist genug oder brauchen Sie?
Die diuretische Therapie ist mit Diuretika richtig.
Aber man muss natürlich den Beta Blocker bei Tachiarithmie.
Er hat ein bekanntes Vorflimmern.
Und die Tachiarithmie absoluter beursacht diese Herzinsuffizienz.
Deswegen müssten Sie eine strikte Herzfrequenzkontrolle machen.
Und Diuretische Therapie.
Damit die Vorlast gesenkt ist.
Bei der Diuretische Therapie besser ist Flora Semit oder?
Flora Semit oder Tora Semit.
Können Sie beides machen. Ist kein Problem.
Das ist wichtig.
Und wenn Beta Blocker nicht ausreicht,
dann muss man überlegen, ob man noch zum Beispiel Digitales dazu gibt.
Beispielsweise.
Aber was Sie nicht gefragt haben, war keiner von Ihnen,
ob der Patient schon mal eine Kardioversion bekommen hat.
Eine. Er hat ja ein Vorflimmern.
Er ist ein recht junger Patient.
Hat keiner von Ihnen gefragt.
Sollte man den Patienten fragen,
ob schon mal eine Herzkatheteruntersuchung gemacht worden ist
und ob schon mal eine sogenannte Kardioversion gemacht ist.
Und weil es noch eine wichtige Frage ist, warum bisher noch keine
Pulmonalablation gemacht worden ist.
Ja, das müssten Sie den Patienten auch fragen heutzutage, weil das eigentlich
standardmäßig die Therapie ist.
Und wenn das alles nicht funktioniert,
dann macht man eine Doack Therapie, also eine Antikoagulation Therapie, bis ans Ende
des Lebens eine lebenslange Doack Therapie.
Ok, ok, vielen Dank für die Information.
Haben wir Kardiologen unter uns?
Wer das besser weiß als ich,
irgendwelche kardiologischen Kollegen hier.
Ok, gut.
Darf ich eine Frage? Bitte.
Wann kann man PaceMaker Herzschlussmaterial durchführen?
Soll ein Patient?
Ja, wenn der Patient eine sehr starke Herzschlussmaterialität hat
oder eine Bradyarythmie entwickelt zum Beispiel.
Aber das muss man den Kardiologen fragen.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Keine Hausarztaufgabe?
Hausarzt macht man nicht, nein.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Das machen die Kardiologen.
Ja, danke.